Is he telling us about. Oh yes well
we went to america and our last tour
and finished up in the game
and hawaii. You'd have
a game you know no i didn't know no longer
to see and if you believe in the golden
oldies are well i play the golden
oldies oh it's quarter short to try
a course was set up
a bit i'll admit we played the
gentleman all new york and we had
a great day of funny things that happened
to you know each is recorded. I believe
around about the place i'd love to see
in some of the other games when you hear
about them but that night i remember that
night we brought the jem one of york over
to our club. And the referee and
we had that on tape and was shown
up in our club at north northern suburbs
rugby club here anyway. One of their
players was
a big tall negro. He must have been about
six foot four or five big tall fell and i
said you know just for
a joke joke and i said how can you get
fifteen gentleman in new york to play rugby
or fifteen general and
then your going to a is
a guy's boy you're the third man
that's asking that question. They are
a great crowd. Now but they heard after
that there was another take all the old
gentlemen of new york. So the two teams
from new york airplane rugby and that tour
. You know but it was
a great great afternoon late afternoon.
You've got any more football story. Rugby
stories or i suppose i'd have
a few you know but i'd have to
throw my mind packed in as well
a little england baby not west worth
recording little sayings. But i can tell you
one great story about
a well known character who everyone our
australian knows and it's about nugget made
norm a fact i'm looking at him on t.v.
Last night. I know and i got very very well
indeed and we were planned against one
another in the third grade game down at
manly oval. So i said to my halfback i said
look if i think his name. I can't think of
a time i said always put it in on the
left hand side whether it's tight head or
loose head. So it's
a that's rather strange always put the ball
in on the lucid side where you got the
benefit of the extra head to hook the
ball back i was planned hooker. I said i
don't like everyone. So i think that's
rather strange you always wanted the ball
put him on the left hand side. I said yes
there is and they got the sight of one
eye. Well
a lot heard what they call me. And they
said and it turned out i mean i got my
because they don't got a sight. When
i you know and i think i got once in
a while then we laugh. You know. So that's
a strike until about no i got my mind.
That's playing for the conditions all right
. Isn't it. Yes or well you play to the
weakness or the other person don't you know
no matter what. What job. I
think. Same and cricket.
Did you play cricket know never play
cricket ever say the oh they only i i've
played about two games at life and they
were fun games. The other game i played was
a bank and games. Well i was down at
mount avail surf club those days and we
invited some of our boys to connect to our
club or work for their rural bank those
days and they knew
a lot of rain we boys so we invited the
randwick boys down to our. We had an old
place down there called
a shack which we eventually bought from
my football club i'd be tossed in and got
it cheap in the early days just after the
war so invite all this rhetoric football
club to play cricket and there were the
famous serial towers since passed away
the great australian rugby player and several
others. I went into bat and i said i
will i'm sure turned about and i'm pulling
on some swim flippers. They said what do
you put the swim flippers on for my said
well they tell me they're there they make
it quicker they serve only in the bloody
water. So i found that out by playing
cricket because i dozed and i got half i
think i hit the ball and start to run and
i fell fell over. So i i proved to the
boys that they they swim rivers don't make
your faster. So that's because my last
game of cricket i played. Oh fun days
. Yes you have the years
that you play work at gilboa
you've got to be what do you do
there. Oh i was started off as
a storm and packer storm and one thing
and another then got a little bit of
a lift when i'm on and i suppose i found
out i was very keen but you had to be keen
as a skipper job anyway where
you eventually you know got
a bit elevated i suppose in the job and to
a. It's better job in the stores. Anyway
eventually when the electric pumps
came on. They said look where we
want to send you to melbourne high
for what sin is
a melbourne to look after things down there
there and we have put in an electric
pumps in melbourne. Now after they came to
sydney and i g. So anyway. They sent me
to melbourne i had to look after the dispatch
of the pumps and make sure everything
went right i got ready and you know
got all the boys down there. So
just organize the distribution of the
pumps and make sure they took the right
materials down for the changeover period
from the old manual pumps which used to
pump up into
a bowl at the top and let down in the car.
And so that was quite interesting and
so well as down there was end of the season
my own rugby season finished so i went
and joined up the melbourne rugby club
had two or three games of them which i
enjoyed but that was that when that finished
i came back to sydney then they sent
me to to adelaide. I thought of it.
This is good to get in see in australia
someone else's expense. I went over to
adelaide done the same job down eventually i
was sent to and then new castle and then
eventually up to brisbane so i got around
so you know i got. Fairly good job there.
Then i became we and charge of the stores
here in sydney and the transport because
then i retired from then they moved up
a long way out us in
a well going from home. They moved up to
what's right. I didn't feel like going of
had my mother then this not too well at
the time i suppose get on and yes i paid
off my house and paid off my car i
thought i. Damn it all. I'll get
a small pension from the
your back. And mum was on
a army pension the whole man to join
the army as early days never went away
as he told and he was a t b l and i
said well what's there. It was a t
b early too bloody late. Locally
and anyway so we decided i'd
give up and that's when i got the job.
Later on with an z bank but. I've got
a life. I'm still there to tell the story
anyway. No regrets no regrets. No no
regrets no regrets. Oh well i suppose for
the same life i would tell i had to live
a game of do that as one of our stroman and
poet said if i had life over that i had
to live game. I do the same things over.
If i had to live again as was his word. So
adam is a good and i think
said that. And i share
a past time and i've done my share of toil
and life is short. The longest life span
. I care not about
a tariff or the corner for the oil
or the you know i think something's
trying to think of the four words i.
Something or other did you ever go in for
a stepford reciting no no no i. Now like i
suppose i am quit on earth as
a bucks do i could tell some great stories
and some of them or australians and some
of my rugby stories. Got it or you could
say no no i have very in mind this
is modern times in the u.s.
You know
a lot of things you know. Well i suppose i
can always tell one story about this is
told to me by. At i do you
know we had around club
a rugby dinner by the late. Chief
justice. Les herron lesley herring.
Unless it's on this story because he was
a great after dinner speaking
always tell the story which he had
a lot of stories to tell. I could tell
a couple if you want to hear them. But this
is one always stuck in my mind which he
told and that was this fella watching this
international going on and one fellow
was very hard of hearin. And it was this
chap it was playing with kicking goals
hear them from area drop kicking field
goals and penalty goals from the sideline
using wizard kicking. So one fill in the
past not the message and. What are you
doing it said he's an italian. I
said like that. So he said what is
a he said he's an italian. I was told
i know one of the bugger can kick
the story you know what i can
always tell about the this is
a sports story about the golfer and he was
a live golf everywhere golf golf golf.
So is going overseas to play in
a tiny over there or over in the pacific
island somewhere to play in the twenty
there and
a plane crash and he was the only survivor
managed to get up to this lovely little
island exhort he throws himself down and
he passes out. When he comes to there's
a beautiful made lovely. Lovely made
a local girl and she's rubbing them down
with coconut oil and stoking them and
bring them round and he looks
up to her and he said wearable
this is just as on the high island
of so-and-so and so she fell he was
a good looking young both she said would
you like to play around. He said don't
tell me there's a bloody golf
course on this island to.